firstly when did you first hear that the
most employable people will be out
allowed outside for the first time in
ten weeks just a couple of days ago like
everybody else and my concern is that
these changes are coming too soon we
have an R number that is at one or close
to 1 in parts of the country and the
government still hasn't reduced the
alert level from 4 to 3 now these were
meant to be things that should have
happened before these steps were being
taken so my worry is that we are going
to to fast and we can't allow people to
be lulled into a false sense of security
that I suggest that everything's ok
people need to remain very very vigilant
because infection rates in my view are
still too high in parts of England do
you think it's right that you only found
out a couple of days ago you are the
mayor of Greater Manchester it doesn't
give you much time to prepare and the
same for your colleagues around the
country no we would have preferred more
notice but that's been true throughout
this I understand the government has to
take its decisions in the way that it
does but that more notice is always
going to be helpful for people in my
position and I would ask them to do that
but also I've got to ask what more could
be done now to put us in a better
position there's a couple of things I
think need to have been number one we've
got to empower the public with more
information trust in their own judgement
to make the right decisions particularly
for those people who've been in the
shielded population now they need to
decide how quickly to change their
routine so let's have the our number
published on a regional basis starting
now so that people can judge the level
of risk in different parts of the
country because it's not the same all
over England the second thing I would
suggest to the government is to allow
the scientists to front up the daily
briefing for the next couple of weeks at
least back in 2009 I made the mistake as
a politician of making too many public
statements during swine flu and the
truth is politician statements are
always going to be more contested and
more controversial
I think the scientist needs to consent
to stage now and it's got to be purely
about the facts the information that
people need about the spread of the
virus
is crucial as we go into this more risky
phase of the pandemic and on public
statements I mean I saw you tweeted
yesterday so we're at a dangerous moment
but don't worry everyone the Premier
League is back soon and we'll be free on
telly nothing that's all contradictory
about today's daily briefing what did
you mean by that tweet well we had the
deputy chief medical officer saying that
it remains a very dangerous moment and
at the same time the culture secretary
something next to him saying Oh
footballs returning Racing's returning
and to me that that appeared to be a
contradictory message that was being
sent out from 10 Downing Street I don't
think we should be making announcements
about football at the daily briefing as
I said a moment ago for me it should be
purely about the science the facts where
are we up to with this virus across
England we had the Foreign Secretary on
the mark program this morning talking
about the localized information he has
in different parts of the country well
why is that not being made public that
people see what is happening on the
ground in their community so that they
can make their own judgments personally
I don't think these daily briefings are
working any more they look like a PR
opportunity for ministers when in fact
what they need to be is highly factual
giving people the evidence of where this
virus is up to and I would say this
mistake back in 2009 so I'm not come
saying that you're preaching to them on
point scoring I made that mistake and
then decided to allow the then chief
medical officer only to front the
briefings and I would say the same to
this current government I think it will
be the best way to restore public trust
which has been damaged in recent days
the foreign controls respect to M safety
Ridge M this morning I mean say so are
you telling us that you believe that the
government is giving us mixed messages
and if that is the case do you believe
that the government is putting people's
lives at risk as we try to get out of
this pandemic I certainly think they're
providing mixed messages at the moment
as I said yesterday there was a very
different message coming from the
experts as opposed to the the politician
and that's a problem and I think the
government needs to work hard now to get
the public health messaging back to
where it needs to be with moralizing put
at risk
of that mixed messaging well I'm
obviously that they are just because of
that what happened yesterday what they
could be if we don't get this sorted out
and we don't restore public trust in the
in the the strength of the public health
messaging now it's taking a knock in
recent days and it's why I'm saying you
know let's have the experts front and
center now for a couple of weeks so that
we can have just factual information
about where the virus is up to I think
what hasn't served us well in the course
of this is ministers kind of coming to
the briefing and promising to have this
many tests by this many date or making
announcements about football as we saw
yesterday you know that should take
place in a different arena at the
briefing give people the facts in mr.
Birnam where do you stand on schools
reopening from tomorrow a lot of
questions about the tests and trace and
isolates program many are questioning
whether it's for the operational well it
isn't and I can only speak for Greater
Manchester and I can tell you that it
isn't fully operational in Greater
Manchester it's getting there but it
will be a couple of weeks until it's
fully functional and that I guess is
what I'm saying to you today I would
have waited to make any changes to have
that system fully in place and certainly
with regard to schools I wouldn't have
really allowed schools to come back at
all until that test and tray system that
was was fully functional so the position
that I would take now is allow
flexibility to schools and councils in
different areas to judge the local
circumstances with regard to spread of
the virus and the number of new cases
and that's what's happening in Greater
Manchester of course we want to see
students back in schools of course we do
but it's got to be done safely and what
you're seeing here is schools coming
back over the next two or three weeks
using their judgment and I think that's
the right way to go and do you think the
government is being led by the silence
when it makes these decisions for
schools for example and also other an
easing of restrictions well scientists
have been saying over that weekend that
they don't feel comfortable with the
speed of the changes that are being made
and one I think described them as
political decisions so
it's clear that the science isn't
leading some of what is now happening
we've heard throughout the government
saying it's been led by the science but
that I think has changed over over the
last few days and it's why I say let the
public hear the science because even if
they've got more potential freedom still
empower them with information so that
they can choose how much change to make
in their lives and how much they should
sort of stick to the to the cautious
side of this that's why honestly I think
the best thing that could happen now
would be for the experts to front those
daily briefings and they should be
absolutely empowered to speak freely and
fearlessly to the public you know not
worrying about a politician cutting them
off as we saw last week let them speak
to the nation and then let the public
decide how they want to deal with the
situation that they face in their own
community